يعني ان تساعدنا في الفهم سيد مجدي عبد
العزيز عندما اطرح هذا السؤال واقول من
المستفيد دعني اضيف على ذلك او من يظن انه
سوف يكون مستفيدا وما هي هذه الفائده من
هذا الصدام حسب متابعتك كصحافي
كمحلل سياسي
يا سيدي قياده الدعم السريع بهذا السلوك
اليوم ارادت ان تصلب واقعا جديدا كان
الحديث صحيح حديثا سياسيا وكان هناك
خلافات في المسائل الفنيه والمسائل
الامنيه ان هذه التحركات
فسرت من قبل حادثه مرور وبعد حادثه مروي
فسرت هي ابتزاز عسكيف امر واقع وكما قلت
في لقاء سابق انها مثل الذي وضع خنجرا في
خاطره القوات المسلحه ليدفعها الى تزيد
اهداف معينه بطريقه معينه ولكن حينما لم
تنفذ هذه الاهداف بهذه الطريقه يبدو انها
قررت ان تقلب الطاوله تماما وتهيت اتحدث
عن استيلاءه للقياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه والمطارات هذه عمليه انقلاب كامله
ارادت قوه مسانده تمردت وهي الان خرجت حتى
على قانونها وعلى قانون القوات المسلحه
وعلى الدستور يعني الحين ما قلت ان هذا
امر عسكري فرض نفسه اريد ان اقول هذا انها
هي الان كسر كل القوانين وكل الاعراف
وخانه القوات المسلحه التي هي نشات في
حكمها وحاولت ان تغتال قائدها وحاولت ان
تقتحم القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
لتفرض واقعا صيفيا جديدا وهو واقع معلوم
انهم ايضا من اطراف سياسيه سيد احمد يحيى
اليست الحقيقه لم يكن يقال دائما ان قوات
الدعم السريعه هي جزء من القوات المسلحه
وان كانت جزءا من القوات المسلحه فلا يجب
ان تاتمر بامر قياده القوات المسلحه
وبالتالي انا يجعلها هذا متمرده ما نعرفه
ان رئيس مجلس هناك رئيس مجلس السياده هناك
قائد اعلى للقوات المسلحه وكل الجيش يجب
ان يعتمر بامره القياده اليس كذلك
مؤكد يجب ان يعتبر بامر القياده لكن هناك
ثمه اشياء سياسيه خلافيه بينهم فيما يخص
الاتفاق الاطاري ودخول المؤسسه العسكريه
في العمل السياسي بحكم الواقع
الذي يعيشه السودان وواقع استثنائي جعل
القوات المسلحه يكون لها باع في العمل
السياسي
وتباين الرؤى ما بين الدعم السريع او
قائده وما بين السيده فريق البرهان فيما
يخص
الاتفاقيه او الاتفاق
وظهور اشكاليه اخرى بعد هذه الورش التي تم
نقاطها في قاضي الصداقه خمسه ورش الورش
الورث الاخيره والخاتمه
هذا احمد هناك من يصفه انه في النهايه
يسمى تمردا ويسمى محاوله بالانقلاب على
قياده الجيش الذي يجب ان كما قلت يعني ان
تعتمر باوامره قوات الدعم السريع وقائد
قوات الدعم السريع
والمواصفات وشكل الالقاب التي يطلقها كل
شخصي هذا امر
عليه مرجعيه الشخصيه
لكن الواقع نفسها الخلافيه بين المجموعتين
اللتين ينتمي الى المؤشر العسكريه هي
واقعه خلافيه
مرجعيتها سياسيه فيما يخص الاتفاق الاطري
وفي
الجزء الثاني المهم ايضا وهو مساله الدمج
القوات الدعم السريع من عدمه والفترات
التي كانت يمكن النقاش حولها وتم طرحها ما
بين الوسطاء وما بين قوات الدعم السريع
وقوات المسلحه والاختلاف الرؤى هنا ما بين
20 سنه و10 سنه وسنتين الرؤى كانوا قد
اختلفت وهذا ايضا شكل مبتخلافيه بالتالي
هي الازمه الحقيقيه في ان في السودان
نحتاج الى قواعد وقوانين ومضاده واسس تحدد
تعاطي المؤسسه العسكريه مع العمل